an airport dash for a Chancellor Under
Pressure quasi-quartang's car
disappeared into the Washington night
after an embassy event and a hastily
rearranged early departure
he'd spent the day at the international
monetary fund's annual meeting defending
his mini budget even as rumors of
another U-turn swirled across the
Atlantic our position hasn't changed I
will come up with the medium-term fiscal
plan on the 31st of October as I said
earlier in the week and there'll be more
detail there and you'll be Chancellor
and Liz truss will be prime minister
this time next month absolutely 100 I'm
not going anywhere
he wasn't at the big meetings through
the day like the G20 Gathering of
Finance ministers and Bank Chiefs
words move markets and so there were
very few here the German bank chief so
what's your reaction to what's happening
in the UK at the moment
the European Central Bank president
what's your what's your reaction to
what's happening in the UK the U.S
treasury secretary what's your message
to the UK Chancellor at the moment
but the chancellor wasn't here instead a
UK official red government binder in
hand explained to organizers that a
deputy would step in for the closed-door
meeting not entirely unusual but
surprising given that they do all want
to know what's happening in London any
reason why the chancellor wasn't there
that's a question
a few rooms away the IMF boss arrived
for her keynote news conference we have
a world economy that has been hit
by one shock after another
an unrelented pandemic
Russia's invasion of Ukraine
climate disasters on all continents
it was a sobering reminder of a global
economy on the Rocks you said um in your
opening remarks that a complex time
requires steady hands on the policy
levers so my question simply is do you
think the British government's hands are
steady if the evidence is that there has
to be a recalibration it is right for
governments to do so the bank of England
action was appropriate there was a
Financial
Risk to to financial stability
she and the chancellor met before his
early departure the focus the IMF says
was the importance of policy coherence
the chancellor is back in London early
he says to focus on a coherent fiscal
plan Mark Stone Sky News in Washington